[Musique]
le
installée depuis début mars pour l'or
les journées sont longues d'éditeurs
réception des livraisons et l'épicière
ne laisse rien au hasard
mais toute la phrase pas la même
quelques photos pour présenter les
produits sur sa page facebook
car ici les clients achètent à distance
fait que de la commande
aux prises de commandes la veille pour
avoir trahi le lendemain avec un horaire
convenu donc vous allez voir du coup il
ya plus du tout d'attentes puisque les
gens là les attendait 1h30 2h magasin la
clé des champs je vous rappelle pour
votre commande
finie la tente mais quel travail
la commerçante doit appeler un à un ses
clients avant les premiers retraits ou
dans la soirée chaque minute compte
très bonne journée merci on appelle
jusqu'à 10h puisqu'à propres après dix
ans je répond plus au téléphone je
touche du téléphone jusqu'à ce soir je
fragmente toutes les étapes de travail
en fait il ya un moment pour appeler un
moment pour recevoir mon préparer à mon
projet c'est votre retirer parce que si
on fait tout en même temps c'était juste
pas gérable pour mettre en place cette
organisation il a fallu embaucher
pas évident quand on vient de
s'installer pour la préparation des
commandes
l'or a fait appel à un ami lui aussi
commerçants normalement je suis coiffeur
en ville et donc du coup depuis un mois
et demi
obligé d'avoir fait de faire des salons
donc j'ai à donner un coup de main et
puis comme ça du coup ça occupe durant
le confinement ça évite de rester à la
maison comme ça on sent un peu utile
10h45
c'est parti premier retraite commandes
pour vous pas d'attentes la promesse est
tenue et les distances respecter ce qui
n'empêche pas de plaisanter
oui vraiment une très très bonne idée de
salon et qui fonctionne bien je pense
qu'elle n'aura pas de souci les gens
n'auront pas de souci d c'est dingue
journée au revoir
[Musique]
des gestes barrières sont mis en place
depuis le début et c'est vraiment des
très bons produits il passe beaucoup de
temps à beaucoup d'énergie à nous rendre
au service tout est trop souvent on a
des premiers coffrets ou nous on est du
quartier donc c'est juste à côté donc
c'est parfait des produits le plus
souvent locaux des services
résultat les affaires sont plutôt
prospère leurs en est même la première
surprise
peut-être qu'ils ont un peu peur d'aller
dans des endroits où il ya quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de monde
ma clientèle qui était déjà créé ben
parle beaucoup passé on est vraiment sûr
à une ambiance de village donc le bouche
à oreille fait qu un client satisfait
pas des fois vraiment mené 2-3 et les
gens là aujourd'hui il trouve vraiment
du confort noms qui reviennent et l'or
ne s'arrête pas là les clients les plus
fragiles elles ce que même de la
livraison
tout ça sans supplément